what are you doing is the category
there's a quick look at puzzle and the
sound means time is running short yep
it's officially the end of an era as Pat
Sajak reveals he's retiring as host of
Wheel of Fortune the show's still
popular I'd like to leave before people
tune in and look at me and say oh what
happened to him the longtime TV person
over 40
is on the Beloved game show
airing on Twitter that it's been a
wonderful ride but the 41st season will
be his last we're getting near the end I
mean it's been a long time we're not
going to do this for another 40 years
it's an honor to have been asked in the
people's living rooms that long I mean
people often wear out their welcome in
our business and we're happy and proud
that we haven't and once again Pat Sajak
to make Pat who served as hosts since
1981 told ET last year that while he's
loved his role he knew he'd have to walk
away eventually in most television shows
this kind of show by this time you would
have said that's probably enough but the
show will not will not die it appears
and I may go before the show as for
weather hits co-host Vanna White will
remain on the show for now it's still
unclear fans can catch Pat make his
final appearances when Wheel of Fortune
returns in September we'll be back and I
don't know what the heck's gonna happen
foreign